histoire sur france 2
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi
yvan colonna condamné à la prison à
perpétuité sans peine de sûreté le
verdict rendu il ya quarante minutes a
été accueillie par les cris de
protestation
les partisans de l'accusé nous serons en
direct au palais de justice de paris et
à ajaccio l'europe se relance les 27
pays de l'union ont solennellement signé
le traité de lisbonne il remplace la
constitution européenne rejetée par la
france et les pays bas en 2005 le
colonel kadhafi prend son temps en
france il a visité le louvre aujourd'hui
au même moment claude guéant était
interrogé par la commission d' enquête
parlementaire sur la libération des
infirmières bulgares un plan pour lutter
contre le gâchis de l'échec à
l'université valérie pécresse annonce
une première année plus générale des
cours plus encadrées et un enseignant
référent un projet bien accueilli enfin
la mort de philippe clay chanteur acteur
de cinéma et de théâtre
il avait 80 ans tout de suite donc
direction le palais de justice de paris
après cinq heures de délibération le
jury composé de magistrats
professionnels a donc condamné yvan
colonna à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité pour le meurtre du préfet
erignac yvan colonna qui annonce qu'il
va faire appel
image et première réaction avec zine
dine boudaoud et jean-marc new look
liberta liberta ont crié les amis d'
yvan colonna à l'énoncé du verdict à
l'extérieur de la cour d'assises ses
partisans convaincus de son innocence
sans assommer par le verdict
sans sarkozy l'avait dit sa cousine on
arrêter l'assassin de la peine pour tout
le monde
et pas de gagnant nous pensons que sur
le plan du droit pour la voie suivie de
très près il n'y avait pas de preuves
explicite de l'implication de colonnes
et qu'on lui demandait en alternance de
faire la preuve de son innocence
il appartenait sur tours à la cour et au
ministère public d'apporter la preuve sa
participation nous allons dès sur
aussitôt relevé appel yvan colonna dit
au juge qui venait de le condamner
il a dit en corse et en français je suis
innocent nous allons nous battre nous
allons faire reconnaître cette innocence
les proches d'yvan colonna sont sous le
choc
pour l'instant ni la veuve du préfet
erignac ni son avocat n'ont réagi à ce
verdict
bonsoir dominique verdeilhan vous êtes
en direct au palais du fou avait suivi
tout le procès on peut dire que ce
verdict n'est pas vraiment une surprise
oui en même temps tout était possible
parce que tout au long de ce verdict on
est passé d'une conviction à une autre
alors ce qu'on peut dire ce soir c'est
que yvan colonna est considéré par la
justice comme le septième homme comme le
membre du commando j'allais dire qui
manquait à ce procès et dans une
certaine mesure c'est une réponse
évidemment pour un certain nombre de
personnes alors il est condamné à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité sans
période de sûreté ce qui veut dire qu'il
est au même niveau que pierre alessandri
et qu'alain ferrandi qui ont été
condamnés dans le procès en 2003 se veut
dire qu'il y à une énigme
on ne sait pas véritablement qui est le
tueur dans ce dossier en tout cas les
dénégations les rétractations des
membres du commando n'ont pas plus
convaincu les juges qu'il n'avait
convaincu
yvan colonna lui même je crois qu'il
faut surtout retenir de ce verdict ce
soir ce sont des images assez forte d'un
côté la famille d'yvan colonna qui était
véritablement sous le choc sur le banc
qui était presque au bord du malaise
pour le père et à quelques mètres d'eux
une famille qui avait entendu ce verdict
avec dignité avec quelques larmes la
famille du préfet claude erignac et tout
le monde était convaincu qu en quelque
sorte
il fallait se re donné rendez vous pour
un procès en appel dans à peu près un an
merci dominique d'autres réactions
maintenant nous allons à ajaccio dans
l'après-midi quelque 150 proches ou
partisan d' yvan colonna s'était
rassemblée
dans la tente de ce verdict sur place
nathalie jour damrémont châtelard devant
le palais de justice d'ajaccio 150
personnes attendent le verdict 19h30
l' annonce tombe c'est la colère
aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas des juges qui
ont rendu un verdict ce sont des
justiciers ça nous ramène et qu'elle est
en arrière à l'intérieur du dôme haut
rang qui arrivait dans les villages
qu'ils aient brûlé équipe rendait les
gens sans aucune forme de procès vive le
peuple corse est notre regard
aujourd'hui ce tour le père yvan colonna
innocent injustement condamné et à toute
sa famille social
nous sommes consternés par le verdict
qui vient de tomber et yvan colonna est
innocent il a toujours affirmé on nous
le réaffirmerons encore je suppose que
ses conseils vont certainement
interjetté appel la décision qui vient
de tomber
les nationalistes entend donner une
réponse à la mesure de la décision qui
vient d'être rendue
ils ont immédiatement appelé à un grand
rassemblement à corte le 17 décembre
prochain
bonsoir nathalie jourdan vous êtes en
direct d'ajaccio on a entendu ses
réactions
quelle est l'atmosphère en ce moment sur
place
écoutez les manifestants se sont
dispersés dans le calme il ya quelques
minutes à peine
il y avait beaucoup de jeunes des
lycéens des étudiants membres du
mouvement de la jeunesse indépendantiste
pour eux yvan colonna c'est le symbole
de la lutte corse
ils se sont d'ailleurs qui ont accroché
derrière nous sur la façade du palais de
justice une banderole avec l'inscription
liberta pour ces jeunes comme pour le
comité anti répression
yvan colonna était innocent sur qui
plane et la présomption de culpabilité
le verdict rendu à paris ce soir ne fait
que les conforter dans leur conviction
merci nathalie voilà ce qu'on pouvait
dire sur ce sujet je vous rappelle donc
qu'yvan colonna était condamné à la
réclusion criminelle à la perpétuité
pour l'assassinât du préfet erignac
pas de réaction donc pour l'instant de
la famille erignac nous y reviendrons
éventuellement dans le courant de ce
journal on en vient à l'europe qui
tourne une page et qui se relancent les
27 pays ont donc signé officiellement le
traité de lisbonne aujourd'hui le texte
définit le cadre et les règles de
fonctionnement de l'union pour faciliter
la prise de décision il remplace donc la
constitution repoussé il y a deux ans et
demi par référendum une cérémonie à
grand spectacle
jeff vite imbert fred furnemont
mini-traité peut-être mais grand
spectacle ce matin dans le prestigieux
monastère de lisbonne l'europe qui signe
sa nouvelle charte
le portugal voulait que musique et des
corps soit à la hauteur
ce sont des dirigeants pressé de sortir
de la crise qui sont arrivés ici
l'intérieur comme sur un plateau de
télévision à l'appel du nom de leur pays
ils viennent mettre leur part à 27 chefs
d'état l'un après l'autre et un couac le
britannique gordon brown signera après
tous les autres dans l'après midi à la
sortie humeur quasi euphorique de ce que
l'on a coutume d'appeler le couple
franco allemand
c'est la lune de miel monsieur le
président et en cas là il demande de
manger des animaux nous coopérons
précise la chancelière 2005 13 décembre
depuis le jour où la france a dit non à
la constitution européenne il aura donc
fallu deux ans et demi pour passer d'un
traité à l'autre pas si différent sur le
fond la constitution inscrivait dans le
marbre à nimy un drapeau commun
le traité de lisbonne ne l'imposent plus
un président pour l'europe il y en aura
bien quand le traité entrera en vigueur
le ministre des affaires étrangères
prévue par la constitution se transforme
en or présente sur 27 pays seule
l'irlande a prévu un référendum tous les
autres passeront par la voie
référendaire moins de risque de rejet
mais beaucoup d'insatisfactions aussi
aujourd'hui en a manifesté au portugal
et en france ce qu'ils avaient dit non à
droite comme à gauche sont furieux
on veut faire passer aujourd'hui
exactement le même texte sans consulter
les français
moi j'appelle ça un coup d'état on a un
peu de mal à adhérer à un texte de cette
nature ce qui serait normal que même ses
coûts demande son avis au peuple
en france le congrès devrait adopter le
traité de lisbonne début février
bonsoir françois vos données vous êtes
notre expert européen en direct de
lisbonne alors pour y voir bien clair
est-ce qu'on peut finalement considéré
que ce texte est à peu près le même que
celui de 2005 mais qui revient sous une
autre forme
le traité de lisbonne qui a été signé
ici derrière moi il ya quelques heures
est une réplique fidèle à 90% de la
constitution européenne pour prendre une
image
je dirais que c'est un peu comme des
frères jumeaux qui portrait des
vêtements de couleur différente en fait
tout se joue dans l'apparence alors
pourquoi
et bien parce que depuis deux ans un
bataillon de juristes européens a repris
le traité de nice d'un côté le texte de
la constitution européenne de l'autre
ils ont expurgé la constitution
européenne que tout ce qu'ils pouvaient
choquer ils ont réuni avec le traité de
nice et cela donne aujourd'hui un texte
très compliqué compréhensible justement
uniquement par les juristes un texte de
300 pages alors est-ce qu'il est
scandaleux d'avoir procédé ainsi
est ce que la démocratie européenne ce
soir est perdante ou au contraire est-ce
qu'il s'agissait d'un passage obligé
pour relancer l'europe est bien là je
crois qu'il s'agit à chacun de se faire
sa propre opinion
merci françois on entendait des
réactions des opposants au texte de 2005
tout à l'heure elle se multiplie le
parti communiste part d'un coup de force
jean-marie le pen d'un déni de
démocratie
la suite de la visite du colonel kadhafi
à paris visite qui est entré maintenant
dans une phase privé le numéro un libyen
fait durer le plaisir
il s'est rendu au louvre tout à l'heure
une petite demi-heure à peine le temps
d'admirer la joconde ou encore le radeau
de la méduse
pendant ce temps nicolas sarkozy
recevait à l'elysée les proches des
victimes de l'attentât du dc-10 d'uta
jérôme bernard stéphane guillemot
une police omniprésente même la gare de
monthey est sollicité à lui seul
mouammar kadhafi a une fois encore
bloqué la circulation à paris
aujourd'hui il jette son dévolu sur le
louvre le dirigeant libyen à 1h30 de
retard il s'est paraît-il arrêter et
faire des emplettes
mais pour une fois le guide a trouvé un
autre guide le directeur du louvre en
personne une visite menée au pas de
charge trois minutes devant la joconde
le public est tenu à l'écart mais le
célèbre musée n'a pas voulu fermer ses
portes
la victoire de samothrace n'est pas
celle du public
il me fait perdre mon temps
mais il ya encore d'autres gêneurs les
photographes le guide de l'espace il
donne ses consignes
devant aveyronnaise les amazones
l'entourent comme toujours elle veille
et profitent elles aussi les oeuvres la
vénus de milo le radeau de la méduse en
30 minutes
la visite est bouclée
pas très loin de là et ce n'est pas un
hasard nicolas sarkozy reçoit les
familles des victimes de l'attentât du
dc-10 d'uta
c'est la première fois depuis 1989
qu'elles sont reçus à l'elysée pour ces
familles kadhafi est le symbole de cet
acte terroriste
sa présence est douloureuse c'est parce
que france c'est une difficulté c'est à
dire c'est quelque chose qui est
difficile à dire en ce sens où il est
une réminiscence de de l'attentât ne
serait ce que par sa présence à ya qu'à
voir l'émotion que ça suscite le colonel
kadhafi lui continue sa visite à titre
privé jusqu'à samedi
un programme encore imprévisibles et
puis c'est aujourd'hui que le secrétaire
général de l'elysée claude guéant était
appelé à témoigner devant la commission
d' enquête parlementaire sur la
libération des infirmières bulgares et
du médecin palestinien
il a assuré une nouvelle fois qu'il n'y
avait eu aucune contrepartie
thierry curtet lionel langlade à défaut
de l'ex épouse du président de la
république la commission denquête
entendait aujourd'hui le plus proche
collaborateur de nicolas sarkozy claude
guéant accompagné cécilia lors des deux
voyages en libye
aujourd'hui il explique que ce sont en
fait les libyens qui entrent en contact
avec lui ou lendemain de l'élection
présidentielle française
je ne dis pas que j'ai été contacté par
la libye je dis que j'ai été contacté
par un responsable libyen je dis cela
parce qu'il n'est pas certain que le
point de vue qu'il m'exposais était
partagée par l'ensemble de l'entourage
du colonel kadhafi plus loin elle
confirme c'est bien cécilia sarkozy qui
seul à seul emporte la décision du
colonel kadhafi grâce à des arguments
humanitaires entre autres pour le
président socialiste de la commission
les contreparties françaises n'étaient
pas économique désormais d'une certaine
façon ce prix politique est connue
voilà on sait ce qui était chercher
l'origine ce que le pm kadhafi voulait
c'était d'être réhabilité réinsérer d'un
comité international et pour lui ça
passait je crois par des relations
fortes avec paris claude guéant assiste
sans la libération des infirmières le
colonel kadhafi ne serait pas en visite
à paris aujourd'hui
on a appris aujourd'hui que c'est dans
huit jours le vendredi 21 décembre que
se tiendra au tchad le procès des
membres de l'arche de zoé
voici les dernières images des six
français retenu là bas elles ont été
tournées aujourd'hui dans une lettre
eric breteau le président de
l'association estime que l'instruction a
été truquée et qu'elle est mensongère
rappelons que trois tchadien est un
réfugié soudanais seront également jugés
et risquent de 5 à 20 ans de prison
valérie pécresse annonce une réforme des
premières années à l'université pour
lutter contre l'échec
il faut savoir que sur les 280 mille
étudiants qui s'inscrivent chaque
rentrée pour la première fois plus de la
moitié échoue dès la première année
c'est pour éviter ce gâchis que ses
propositions étaient présentés notamment
un meilleur encadrement et un enseignant
référent
le détail mallory aonuma rica zoo
premières années sur les bancs de
l'université
un étudiant sur deux risque d'échouer
avec son plan valérie pécresse veut
réduire ce taux de moitié la licence
sera désormais moins spécialisés la
première année devient
pluridisciplinaire culture générale
méthode cours d'anglais sont
obligatoires
la spécialisation n'intervient qu'en
dernières années avec un stage validé
deuxième chantier l'accompagnement les
étudiants seront encadrés la première
année par un enseignant référent
surtout ils suivront chaque semaine cinq
heures supplémentaires de cours ou de
tutorat tutorat obligatoire en cas de
difficultés enfin l'orientation
commencera dès la terminale avec des pré
inscriptions et se poursuivra toute la
première année avec des réorientations
faciliter notamment vers les iut plutôt
bien accueilli le plan sera crédité de
730 millions d'euros d'ici à 2012
il se mettra en place dès janvier dans
les universités volontaires
alors pour mieux comprendre à quoi
pourrait ressembler l'université de
demain il faut savoir que certains
établissements avaient pris les devants
c'est le cas à besançon ou une
expérimentation est menée depuis cinq
ans en filière sciences et techniques
les résultats semblent probants
reportage nabila taboury sylvain
gauthier
geffray et benoît sont étudiants en
première année de sciences et techniques
il aurait pu se retrouver noyé dans un
immense amphithéâtre
accablé par une masse de connaissances
assimilé ce ils ont échappé grâce à la
promotion sercel un appel au début de
chaque cours des classes d'à peine une
quinzaine d'étudiants
lorsque la moyenne ailleurs est de 40
c'est dur à l'université des sciences de
besançon les professeurs ont opté pour
la proximité avec leurs étudiants munis
magistraux en amphi réduit travaux
dirigés plus longs contrôles réguliers
des connaissances c'est presque un
retour au lycée
enfin je serais venu ici en semestre
normal sans intrants starter je pense
que j'aurais déjà laissé tomber ce sont
encadrés suivi ça prolonge un peu ce qui
se passe dans les classes de terminale
et quelque part ça les rassure et autres
initiatives
le tutorat que j'ai pas compris du tout
donc ça serait cool de murray expliqué
clairement quoi ok donc là tu vas voir
que langage familier tutoiement de
rigueur mais plusieurs fois par semaine
des étudiants en master à peine plus
âgée assure le soutien scolaire les
tuteurs sont rémunérés les étudiants
confiance succès garanti
ils viennent régulièrement parce que il
se rend compte que c'est une approche
différente de celle du prof
complémentaires et qui les aide vraiment
à mieux assimiler à mieux assimiler le
coup les professeurs se relaie aussi
pour écouter les étudiants de première
année
résultat moins d'un sur dix abandonnent
en cours de route et en cinq ans les
taux de réussite en premier cycle est
passé de 55 80 % des nouvelles du sommet
de bali avec d'abord une image étonnante
jean louis borloo en caleçon le ministre
de l'écologie a quitté chemise et
pantalon pour un plongeon imprévu il a
été planté un morceau de corail sur le
fond marin c'est une expérience qui est
en cours là bas en ce qui concerne le
sommet lui-même c'est le suspense des
négociations à l'arraché sont en cours
pour tenter de trouver un compromis sur
un texte qui fixerait les objectifs de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre à
l'horizon 2020
al gore auréolé de son prix nobel a
ouvertement mis en cause les états unis
comme responsables d'un éventuel échec
la maison blanche lui a répondu qu'il se
trompait personne ne sait si un accord
sera finalement trouvé mais si c'est le
cas il impliquera des économies
d'énergie drastique et aussi sans aucun
doute un recours accru au nucléaire il
faut savoir que 31 pays abrite
aujourd'hui les centrales la france est
en pointe mais le débat reste très vif
sur la question de la contamination et
du retraitement des déchets où en est on
sur le nucléaire c'est le dossier de
cette émission il est signé frédéric
mentait et frédéric capron tricastin un
des hauts lieux du nucléaire en france
4 centrale est une usine
d'enrichissement d'uranium
visible depuis la route problèmes aux
abords des bâtiments dans les parties
accessibles au public
le compteur geiger s'affolent
ici on a un niveau de rayonnement gamma
qui est de l'ordre de 380 400 coups par
seconde
c'est à dire six à sept fois supérieure
au niveau naturel parce qu'il ya autour
de nous des matières radioactives qui
sont entreposés dans ses fûts au loin
dans les hangars quelles conséquences
pour la santé
difficile à évaluer d'autant plus qu'au
siège d'edf
la direction ne juge pas utile de nous
accorder une interview
c'est d'ailleurs à cause d'un manque
d'information du public que le conseil
d'état a suspendu le démantèlement de
brennilis en bretagne l'une des toutes
premières centrales nucléaires
françaises il manquait notamment une
évaluation de la pollution générée par
la déconstruction de quoi relancer un
débat sans fin
on a en permanence même au japon en
grande-bretagne en suède des risques
d'accident les critères sont
particulièrement sévères et toujours
réévalué à la hausse pour avoir le
minimum de risques
d'accord ou pas le nucléaire fournit 78
% de notre électricité suivie de loin
par les barrages hydrauliques et les
centrales thermiques les énergies dites
vertes ne représente qu'un pour cent
pourquoi une telle hégémonie parce que
tous les présidents depuis le général de
gaulle ont misé sur le nucléaire
puissance nucléaire comme on dit est
liée directement à l'énergie atomique
elle même qui est comme vous le savez
tous le font de l'activité de demain la
nécessité de l'énergie du gars je n'ai
jamais douté
les précautions à prendre on les prend
et les précautions à prendre dans cet
ascenseur souterrain on les étudie en
permanence au niveau principal du
laboratoire dans la meuse près de
bar-le-duc
les scientifiques évaluent la
possibilité de stocker les déchets
nucléaires selon eux il faudrait 60
kilomètres de galeries trois fois plus
grande que celle ci pour contenir les
déchets les plus toxiques du parc actuel
s'agit bien d'une roche mais c'est une
roche qui a des propriétés mécaniques
tout à fait particulière et surtout
des propriétés de confinement
c'est à dire qu'elle est imperméable
et qu'elle permet de contenir la
radioactivité mais cette roche argileuse
résistera-t-elle à des déchets
radioactifs dangereux pendant des
centaines de milliers d'années à la
surface léger changement de discours
il faudra deux cent mille ans pour que
vraiment est un peu de radio éléments
qui ressortent
mais ils auront tellement décrue en fait
d'une activité d'ici là que l'impact
en attendant le nucléaire se vend bien
ici à chalon sur saône
areva bâti les pièces centrales des
réacteurs nucléaires le carnet de
commandes affiche complet pour les trois
ans à venir par sylla par exemple mesure
une dizaine de mètres et pèse entre 52
et va être vendu et qu'il le générateur
de vapeur là est destiné au marché
chinois
on a des contacts avec des appels
d'offre potentielle qui sortent ou qui
sont arrivés ou qui vont arriver pour
l'afrique du sud pour pour les états
unis pour l'angleterre maintenant c'est
en train de se remettre en dehors ouvrir
fait ce type d'énergie il y a 6 ans et
usines frôlé la faillite
aujourd'hui elles embauchent 150
salariés par an le nucléaire civil
rapporte 11 milliards d'euros à la
france chaque année
deux semaines après les émeutes de
villiers-le-bel la ministre de
l'intérieur michèle alliot marie
recevait aujourd'hui les policiers et
les pompiers blessés au cours des deux
nuits d'émeutes elle a remis des
médailles d'acte de courage et de
dévouement voici deux témoignages dont
celui du commissaire de police qui avait
été agressée et battue juste après
l'accident qui a coûté la vie à deux
adolescents alors qu'il venait tenter de
calmer les esprits
lionel feierstein eric de lagnieu ils se
remettent doucement de leurs blessures
de ses deux jours d'émeutes à
villiers-le-bel où 150 policiers et
pompiers ont été pris pour cible parmi
eux la moitié l'a été par arme à feu
comme ce gardien de la paix qui a été
criblée d'une vingtaine de plomb les
cocktails molotov
j'ai incendiaires on s'y attend quelque
peu
mais partie d'émission après qu on
s'inspirait du non on n'a vraiment pas
préparé
ces clichés on pense un petit peu à tout
on pense à sa compagne on pense à sa
famille
on n'a pas envie rester ça même si on
sait qu'on sait dire non non c'est pas
quelques années on ne sait pas ce qu'il
en est réellement arrivé juste après la
collision entre un véhicule de police et
les deux adolescents le commandant il y
a été immédiatement agressé par une
trentaine de jeunes filles nous prendre
à partie il ya eu deux morts il y aura
de morts chez les policiers
voulez-vous tués par l'armée après un
viol at on a tellement monté qu'il
pleuve roué de coups le policier est
évacuée de justesse par un collègue
il s'en sort avec des côtes et un nez
cassé aujourd'hui pourtant deux semaines
après les émeutes
il souhaite retourner dans le quartier
il ya toujours un dialogue possible
y a pas de situation figée la situation
a explosé c'est vrai mais la situation
n'est pas figée je pense que il faut
surtout se battre dans l'europe dans le
cas de notre rôle de policier notre
boulot à nous c'est quoi c'est d'assurer
la tranquillité publique
ces policiers pompiers ont été décorés
ce soir au ministère de l'intérieur
ils recevront également 400 euros de
prime l' enquête concernant la mort des
deux adolescents est toujours en cours à
l'étranger d'abord la surprise aux états
unis mike huckabee un ancien pasteur
inconnu il ya un mois pourrait devenir
le candidat républicain à la maison
blanche
il talonne le favori rudolf giuliani
dans les derniers sondages
et alors que les primaires approche
alain de chalvron aaron diamond
il adore les rolling stones c'est
pourtant la guitare basse n'est pas son
métier
mike huckabee est un politique
pratiquement inconnu il ya un mois
ancien gouverneur d'un petit état
l'arkansas
on n'aurait pas misé un scène sur lui et
le voilà en tête des sondages chez les
républicains
à la une des journaux sous le titre
sainte okbi notre parti est important
mais nos principes sont encore plus
importants et les principes bien sûr ce
sont ceux de la bible mike okbi est
aussi et même avant tout un ancien
pasteur
il est le candidat des évangélistes
qu'aucun autre prétendant républicain ne
satisfaisait le gouverneur local y ait
les mêmes priorités que moi il est
conservateur sur le plan social il est
contre l'avortement et pour la famille
il y à un mois encore ses permanences
électorales étaient vides et sa fille
sarah son seul soutien
les réunions électorales ressemblait
plutôt à des fêtes de famille est le
nerf de la guerre l'argent manquait
cruellement un riche de l'argent vous
pouvez embaucher des gens vous pouvez
voyager acheter des espaces
publicitaires bref on ne naît une
campagne efficace
l'argent coule à flots désormais et on
commence à voir ses spots électoraux
on se presse pour serrer sa main et dans
les débats télévisés on prête
d'attention qu'à lui et à ses réparties
pensez vous que jésus était pour la
peine de mort jésus était trop
intelligent pour votre candidat à un
poste politique
la principale cible des autres candidats
républicains
ça n'est pas encore gagnée pour lui mais
ça promet une campagne intéressante
direction la somalie maintenant avec un
appel de médecins sans frontières
l'organisation humanitaire s'alarme de
la situation des civils dans ce pays
de la corne de l'afrique de l'est livré
à la guerre civile aujourd'hui encore
vous ne voyez un obus a fait 13 morts
la guerre oppose les milices des
tribunaux islamiques parfois comparée
aux talibans aux forces éthiopiennes qui
sont venus les déloger
avec la bienveillance des états unis car
washington redoute là bas une
implantation d'al qaïda nos envoyés
spéciaux dominique derda et frédéric
ranque ont pu se rendre à mogadiscio et
approcher ces fameuses milices voici
leurs reportages
à 26 ans à peine à petit fille tard
ibrahim est l'un des hommes les mieux
protégés de mogadiscio une douzaine au
moins deux gardes du corps à chacune de
ses sorties
il faut dire qu'il a de bonnes raisons
d'être prudents l'an dernier son père
est mort dans l'explosion d'une bombe
placée sur le bord de la route
il était l'adjoint du gouverneur de la
capitale le chef de la sécurité
à sa disparition et happy feet arc a
pris sa succession
mais le jeune héritier n'a pas la tâche
facile les insurgés islamistes
multiplient les attentats et tendent des
embuscades souvent meurtrières la
dernière c'était ici et pas plus tard
qu'hier un mort et cinq ou six blessés
dans les rangs des forces
gouvernementales aux abords de ce
terrain vague
la journée on ne les voit pas ils se
fondent dans la population
ils sortent surtout la nuit ils
commettent des actes de sabotage et ils
disparaissent aussitôt c'est très
difficile qu'on oublie qu on les appelle
les shebab les jeunes la branche la plus
radicale de l'union des tribunaux
islamiques qui de juin décembre 2006 a
régné sur mogadiscio et le sud du pays
de plus en plus populaire les shebab
font figure de résistant face à l'armée
d'occupation éthiopienne qui n'hésite
pas pour ouvrir la route à tirer dans
l'appli c'est sur elle que les
moudjahidine concentrent leurs attaques
l'ethiopie chrétienne est l'ennemi
héréditaire de la somalie musulmane dans
une maison du nord de la ville nous
avons rendez vous avec abdullahi mohamed
c'est son nom de guerre il est l'un des
chefs de la rébellion pour les états
unis qui soutiennent activement les
troupes éthiopiennes en somalie les
shebab sont une organisation terroriste
affilié à al qaïda
nous n'avons entendu parler d'al qaïda
que dans les médias sur tous les médias
américains
nous n'avons qu'une relation avec les
membres d'al qaïda nous connaissons
personne dans leurs rangs nos ennemis ce
sont les éthiopiens et ceux qui
collaborent avec ni les uns ni les
autres ne donne de bilan fiable des
affrontements mais il suffit de se
rendre dans l'un des hôpitaux de
mogadiscio pour constater que les civils
évidemment ne sont pas épargnés
l'autre jour au marché est née chez va
traîner les corps de trois soldats
éthiopiens qu'ils avaient eus ar est et
tout bien qu'à soi que les éthiopiens
sont revenus avec des chars et ont tiré
sur tout ce qui bougeait c'est comme ça
que j'ai des blessés est difficile pour
les habitants de savoir où aller quand
d'un jour à l'autre un quartier paisible
devient un champ de bataille la nuit
dernière et la nuit d'avant il y a eu
des tirs et des bombardements tout
autour de chez nous on n'en peut plus on
n'a plus rien à manger plus rien à boire
et on a peur
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui la plupart
échoue dans des camps de déplacés à la
périphérie de la ville mais il y en a
qui préfèrent s'installer à quelques
rues à peine de leurs maisons en ruines
dans l'espoir sans doute que la guerre
qui est déjà passé par tous ne repassera
pas par là
jadis la place des héros de la
résistance était l'une des plus belles
de mogadiscio après 17 années de guerre
civile
c'est une carrière à ciel ouvert partout
des tas de pierres et de gravats
à l'image d'un pays où tout est à
reconstruire
s'il y avait la paix au moins je le
trouvais du travail
là je ne suis même pas payer l'a fait
pour les plus vieux n'est qu'un lointain
souvenir pour ces enfants
un rêve inaccessible en somalie sur neuf
millions d'habitants près de la moitié a
moins de 18 ans et n'a jamais connu que
la guerre économie on a beaucoup parlé
récemment des produits défectueux en
provenance d'asie et l'asie d'où la
france importe 70% de ses jouets du cou
et à la proche des fêtes de fin d'année
les contrôles sont particulièrement
vigilants voici comment sont réalisés
ces vérifications à l'arrivée des
conteneurs au havre puis dans les
laboratoires reportage caroline thébaux
vincent bouffartigue conteneurs n'a pas
été choisi au hasard provenance
propriétaire des critères qui pousse
aujourd'hui les douaniers à le contrôler
les contrôles ciblés donc fructueux la
proportion de jouets dangereux est à
hauteur à peu près de 30% sur les quais
du havre 9 jouer sur 10 arrivent de
chine
les non conformes sont donc
majoritairement chinois comme cela censé
avoir été testée avant d'être importés
et pourtant celui là la chan qui a une
sur deux sièges en fer blanc
les surprises ne manquent pas il ne faut
pas déchaîner le mordre
car il ya des possibilités que ça
déteigne éviter de laisser au soleil
selon l'étiquette cette folle uche est
même interdite aux jeunes enfants à
dessiner plus de 13 ans ça leur permet
de ne pas faire les rapports d'essais
qui sont censés faire au moment de de la
mise sur le marché donc ça fait ça fait
des francs - ça fait un moyen de se
couvrir
des tests plus poussés sont donc souvent
réalisés dans des laboratoires français
comme celui ci il en existe une dizaine
ainsi rien et épargner aux jouets que
nous leur avons confié
il faut savoir c'est que ce genre de
jouet ont le droit de brûler mais pas
trop vite pour que l'enfant ait le temps
de se dégager du jouet si jamais le
s'enflamme au programme recherche
d'éventuels peinture toxique le plomb
par exemple mais aussi des tests
électromagnétiques pour évaluer
notamment les interférences avec le
téléphone ou les interphones pour bd
après les récents rappels de jouets pour
malfaçon constructeurs et distributeurs
multiplient les contrôles l'activité ici
a doublé ces trois derniers mois
économie encore avec de l'eau au moulin
de ceux qui estiment qu'il ya une baisse
du pouvoir d'achat aux mois de novembre
les prix ont augmenté de 0 5% notamment
en raison de la flambée du pétrole et de
l'alimentaire sur un an la hausse est de
2,4 pour cent
la neige est arrivée en masse un peu
partout en france 80% des stations vont
pouvoir ouvrir leurs portes
les artificiers sont à l'oeuvre pour
déclencher les avalanches préventive
c'est une bonne nouvelle économique car
l'an passé la saison avait été
particulièrement médiocre à villard de
lans près de grenoble benoît gadret jean
claude martin
dans un épais brouillard les dameuses
ont entamé leur ballet divers en trois
jours il est tombé 80 cm de neige à 1500
m d'altitude la poudreuse
c'est très beau mais voici la piste de
retour à la station film est aujourd'hui
la même il y a un an
les skieurs avaient alors déserté la
station entraînant une baisse de 50% du
chiffre d'affaires des remontées
mécaniques pour rattraper cette année le
plus vite possible et on espère bien que
cette saison va nous permettre de
pallier à toute cette problématique
cette neige abondante est aussi un
cadeau du ciel pour les saisonniers du
village stéphane a le sourire il est
déjà au travail
ayala on a eu quinze jours de chômage
partiel oui parce que on avait commencé
et donc à près de la station le prix
pourrait être étonné et donc après ben
nous met au chômage j'ai pu me rendre
chez nous et on attend que j'arrive même
soulagement pour ce loueur de matériel
la saison dernière une partie des skis
n'a pas quitté la boutique
aujourd'hui c'est le cahier de
réservations qui se remplit à l'est déjà
les demandes et puis les gens font déjà
aussi positionné sur la période de
février sur février c'est déjà pas mal
oui c'est là pendant trois jours il a
bien neigé à l'office du tourisme les
demandes pour les vacances de fin
d'année ont été multipliées par deux en
quelques jours la station respire une
partie du domaine skiable sera ouverte
dès ce week-end avec une semaine d'avant
la mort de philippe clay chanteur acteur
de cinéma et de théâtre il avait connu
un grand succès dans les années 50 avant
de connaître une baisse de régime puis
de revenir au premier plan un peu plus
tard il avait 80 ans emmanuel lambert
1971 philippe clay connaît un nouveau
succès
universités s'étaient pas jussieu cet
espace ans cet hymne anti mai 68 mais
universités le catalogue chanteur engagé
à droite réactionnaire même pour
certains mais ses premiers succès datent
des années 50
aznavour prévert vian lui offrent de
nombreux textes il pousse même la
chansonnette avec serge gainsbourg à 16
ans philippe nat b de son vrai nom
s'engage dans la résistance à la fin de
la guerre il entre au conservatoire
national d'art dramatique mime théâtre
chanson sa carrière prend des formes
multiples acteurs pour jean renoir
il aura joué dans une trentaine de longs
métrages et de nombreux téléfilms pour
les connaisseurs le générique des
brigades du tigre
c'était lui
l'une de ses dernières apparitions
c'était au théâtre de la bruyère à paris
l'an dernier il jouait dans la pièce
l'escale philippe clay avait 80 ans
oui on a appris également le décès du
musicien ike turner considéré comme un
des pionniers du rock'n'roll et il
connaîtra le grand succès public dans
les années 60 dans son duo avec une
certaine tina turner leur histoire
tumultueuse à la vie comme à la scène va
durer dix-huit ans ike turner avait 76
ans une image de football
lyon a fait un grand match hier soir en
ligue des champions l'ol s'est imposé en
terre écossaise 3 0 face aux glasgow
rangers c'est se qualifie pour les
huitièmes de finale grâce en particulier
à un étincelant karim benzema une passe
décisive pour signer govou on l'a vu et
un doublé dans les dernières minutes
dont ce tir de loin 3 0 donc pour lyon
qualifié pour la cinquième année
consécutive en huitièmes de finale avant
de refermer cette édition je vous en
rappelle l'un des principaux titres
yvan colonna a été condamné à la prison
à perpétuité tout à l'heure par la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris pour le
meurtre du préfet erignac
on a entendu en début de journal les
avocats et les proches de l'accusé
voici le premier commentaire côté
parties civiles on écoute l'avocat de la
famille erignac
benoît chabert la cour d'assises
aujourd'hui
qui vont colonna est l'assassin du
préfet erignac et prononce une des
peines les plus lourdes du code pénal
qui est la règle à perpétuité et en
aucun cas la partie civile ne commente
la peine ce qui intéresse ce qui est
important pour moi c'est qu'il soit
déclaré coupable ensuite la psv décision
des magistrats
je n'ai pas la commande et yvan colonna
qui va effectivement faire appel c'est
la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo nathalie rihouet le point route
valérie maurice 20h50 envoyé spécial
avec guilaine chenu et françoise joly
avec notamment une enquête sur les
traces des kamikazes en algérie très
bonne soirée
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr